there's a time Jump between the first
and second game in the first game like
in season 1 Ellie is 14 years old and in
the second game Ellie is 19 years old
which puts her closer to 20-year-old
Bella Ramsay's age in real life there
hasn't been any firm confirmation that
there will or will not be a time Jump
between these two seasons that said
Mason does call this time jump in the
game important he also notes that
there's a primary shift in time but
there's also moments that you see that
are in between the events of the main
story line when it comes to Parts one
and two of the game so so it's safe to
assume that this is what we'll be seeing
in season 2 if this has you worried
about the nature of the time Jump though
Mason made one thing clear we are not
doing House of the Dragon leaps those
were very significant leaps in age and
we don't have that so no recasting will
occur not on my watch